people arriving in Hong Kong from abroad
no longer have to take compulsory PCR
tests
that's despite the territory still
recording around 20 000 covid-19 cases a
day
and the reaction among Travelers is
mixed so I was expecting we're going to
have a PCR desk but it's good it feels
like I'm it's back to normal since like
it's increasing the cases
I think they should implement it again
like that timing to cancel it right now
vaccine certificates will also become a
thing of the past previously only those
who had been vaccinated could enter
certain places such as restaurants and
supermarkets
social distancing is also out
we can take away a few of the tables and
give people more room to stand or dance
or what have you so so we're looking
forward to it I think in on the public
sector there's going to be a bit of of
worry for the first couple weeks so I
don't think you'll see the mass Rush of
people coming out I think it's going to
be more of a gradual thing Hong Kong has
largely followed China's lead in
tackling Coronavirus it had some of the
most stringent covet rules in the world
but it's lifting most of them just as
China abandoned its zero covert policy
earlier this month we've been hearing
from Chambers of Commerce up and down
Hong Kong
um that they desperately need to have
these restrictions removed that they
need to get back to a sense of normality
and in particular we need to have
visitors coming to Hong Kong Hong Kong
is very dependent upon tourists
but while the opening up of Hong Kong is
largely welcomed here some countries are
being more cautious Japan has restricted
passenger flights from here to certain
airports
a decision the Hong Kong government says
could affect tens of thousands of people
and if the number of cases continues to
rise more Rules by other countries may
follow
Florence Louis Al Jazeera Hong Kong